from James Cameron's bizarre early 2000
superhero mating ritual to a scene 2
raunchy even for HBO some on-screen
hookups will forever be left to our
imaginations
considered among the most influential
sci-fi films of all time Ridley Scott's
alien centers on a crew of astronauts
whose ship is infiltrated by a violent
predatory extraterrestrial leaving it up
to Sigourney Weaver's Ellen Ripley to
save the day as the Lone Survivor the
character of Ellen Ripley would become a
pop culture icon as a surprising heroine
who drives the most badass moments in
the entire film Indie wire noted that
what audiences love about Ripley is that
she's human and relatable what
[Music]
if you have any trouble I'll be on the
bridge but one moment that would have
shown Ripley's vulnerability and
possibly watered down her lasting image
as a strong no-nonsense woman never made
it past the script in an early version
of the screenplay there was a love scene
between Ripley and another crew member
according to people Weaver objected to
its inclusion upon signing on for the
film and asked Scott would you really
get it on while this thing is running
around ultimately the point was taken
and it was excised in a way Weaver's
question is amusing because plenty of
sci-fi and horror films that have come
along since 1979 bang on near nudity or
paused the action for actors to get it
on the lesson those filmmakers haven't
learned is that the lack of a love scene
kept the movie's tone intact and minted
Ripley as a female icon who didn't have
to rely on sexiness or nudity to appeal
to audiences
a cultural Touchstone of the late 2000s
and early 2010s CW's Gossip Girls
centered on a cast of New York City
socialites including Blake Lively's
Serena Vander Woodsen and her best
friend Blair Waldorf it was
controversial from the jump a frequent
Target of conservative groups for
Content perceived as inappropriate as
often happens the series leaned into the
controversy embracing its risque nature
for marketing purposes however there
were moments throughout the show's sixth
season run that tested even the CW's
willingness to push sexual boundaries
and were subsequently cut some had the
characters interacting with sex toys but
others were more overtly sexual one such
moment involved a tryst between Blair
and Chuck played by Ed Westwick
executive producer Joshua Safran would
later recall to vulture we had a story
about Chuck taking care of Blair under a
table at Zan's I don't think we were
able to do it but we hinted at it this
John McNaughton directed Thriller mixes
an old-fashioned Noir mystery with very
adult steamy subject matter boasting one
of Bill Murray's most off-the-wall
performances and career making work from
breakout Denise Richards how much
[Music]
ostensibly the story of a Miami
detective investigating the sexual
assault of a high schooler by her
guidance counselor the film is filled
with so many twists and turns double
crosses and underhanded dealings that by
the end you'll need a notepad and Pen to
track all the shifting alliances one key
relationship however didn't make the
final cut a romance between Stars Matt
Dillon and Kevin Bacon in some ways the
subplot would have been fairly
revolutionary for its time period and
others this is a film where characters
are constantly revealed to be in bed
together so it would make a lot of sense
McNaughton explained to Yahoo how the
scene was supposed to play out saying in
the original version of the scene Matt
walks into his bathroom to take a shower
and there's Kevin they were supposed to
look each other up and down and then
Wham go at it bacon was totally on board
for the scene he divulged to Total film
I thought it was great because the whole
movie is about Secrets coming out right
as reveals go that one was just huge
unfortunately the financiers didn't like
the idea of men making out they felt it
went too far they felt it wasn't right
I was really sorry about the way that
worked out Dylan however was happy to
see the subplot dropped he explained to
Total film I was relieved when they got
rid of that scene Kevin seemed pretty
attached to it though
not refused to name which actor put the
kibosh on the scene in his interview
with Yahoo it's pretty obvious
regardless he was fine with the scene
being cut he told the publication I love
surprise and I love stuff that I don't
see coming but in that moment it was
like you win some you lose some we're
moving on
arguably the TV series with the most
headline grabbing nudity and sex scenes
throughout its eight seasons this HBO
epic based on the tales of George R.R
Martin followed dozens of story lines
including one that had Emilia Clarke's
Daenerys Targaryen married to Jason
momoa's Dothraki King called Drogo it's
a Savage of course but he's one of the
finest Killers alive
the season one subplot offered up risque
moments between the two actors that ran
the gamut from horrific to romantic in
Martin's original A Song of Ice and Fire
book series however these weren't the
only early sexual moments involving the
mother of dragons in the books Daenerys
has two sexual encounters with Erie one
of her Dothraki handmaidens ultimately
the series omitted the subplot killing
off Erie in the middle of season two in
the first season however Daenerys is
seen instructing another one of her
handmaidens Doria to teach her how to
satisfy her new Dothraki husband in the
bedroom
Sam raimi's eagerly anticipated debut of
the friendly neighborhood web Slinger
contained one of the most iconic kissing
scenes of its era before Remy was
involved however James Cameron intended
something far naughtier than kissing in
the rain when Cameron was attached in
the early 90s his Spider-Man got far
enough that the future Titanic and
Avatar a tour submitted a 47-page
scriptment that told the story of the
origin of Spider-Man using variations on
Electro and Sandman as the baddies even
after Cameron left the project some
elements were retained by eventual
screenwriter David Capp years later
Cameron scriptment leaked online and
readers were intrigued to learn of one
parallel that included a somewhat
graphic sex scene as Cameron described
it Spider-Man takes MJ to the top of the
Brooklyn Bridge tying her down with his
webbing Cameron intended for their sex
to resemble actual biological spider
mating rituals in the script Peter
Parker raises his hands in what is
described as a dance-like movement and
says courtship among the spiders is
highly ritualized it varies from species
to species the male spider May Circle
the female or wave his front legs to
signal that he is not prey in certain
crab spiders such as zysticus the male
will attach strains of silk to the
female tying her limbs another HBO
series that made its name with edgy
content and risque moments of intimacy
girls wasn't set in a medieval fantasy
world but instead the realities of young
people living in Brooklyn I don't need
that I used to your boobs well you don't
get to sorry I only show my boobs to
people on having sex with one moment
that was apparently two potentially
controversial even for girls involved
characters played by Alison Williams and
Andrew Reynolds in the season 2 premiere
Marnie and Elijah an ex-boyfriend of
Hannah's who came out as gay
unexpectedly hook up after an apartment
party gone wrong in the actual episode
The Awkward encounter ends abruptly in
the original version Elijah was intended
to finish on screen the president of
HBO's programming at the time Mike
Lombardo objected to the money shot
nevertheless the creators of girls
eventually got their conclusion shot by
the end of that season in what became a
controversial scene due to its depiction
of non-consensual sex Adam driver's
character has rough sex with his
girlfriend Natalia and he is similarly
depicted as climaxing showrunner Lena
Dunham defended the scene and driver's
character though many viewers felt
Natalya's clear discomfort was a
boundary crossed
a Ranchi went off from the minds of
South Park co-creators Trey Parker and
Matt Stone this Thunderbirds influenced
parody centers on a team of
ultra-patriotic counter-terrorists who
recruit a theater actor to help them
take on the nefarious forces of North
Korea this being a Parker Stone
production fans can expect three things
lots of bad words
a take no prisoner's attitude and a
willingness to go to some deep raunchy
places sure enough Team America made
headlines with a prolonged sex scene
between two of the puppets featuring so
many ridiculous positions that it
briefly earned the film in NC-17 rating
from the Motion Picture Association of
America Parker and stone ultimately cut
the film's original sex scene down since
the MPAA now known as the Motion Picture
Association just doesn't tell filmmakers
what needs to be cut this resulted in an
inevitable guessing game a reported nine
cuts were made before the film was
finally approved to be rated R this
meant that for the film's theatrical
release they had to lose some seriously
sick moments reportedly these scenes
involved urination defecation and other
such acts in subsequent uncut and
international releases of the movie some
of these graphic moments were added back
in some still reportedly remain on The
Cutting Room floor perhaps never to be
seen Parker explained to Entertainment
Weekly in 2004 that the scene was
supposed to be twice as long and that it
would likely be easier to release the
footage in a foreign cut than a domestic
one he added that would just point
something out that America is the only
country that can't see the whole puppet
sex scene
the first Twilight film based on a
series of novels by Stephanie Meyer was
a box office smash when it was released
in 2008 and it would become a huge
cultural influence for years to come
surprisingly the titillating romance
between Robert Pattinson's vampire
Edward and Kristen Stewart's teenage
Bella was quite tame even for a PG-13
movie you better hold on tight spider
monkey as the series continued adapting
Meyer's books they eventually began to
mature alongside the characters and the
Romantic interactions escalated with the
fourth film The Twilight Saga Breaking
Dawn Part 1. following the marriage of
Edward and Bella the two consummate
their relationship despite Bella being a
human after kissing nude in a lake the
two take it to the bedroom where Edward
proceeds to quite literally destroy
their bed in the midst of lovemaking
while it's a lot steamier than anything
fans had previously seen in the film
franchise it was actually toned down
quite a bit from the filmmaker's
original intent certain elements needed
to be excised and the scene had to be
refilmed due to guidelines from the mpa
a about what constitutes as PG-13 it was
a tough line to walk for the actors
Stewart told Harper's Bazaar it had to
be Transcendent and otherworldly inhuman
better sex than you can possibly ever
imagine
there's no shortage of steamy love
scenes in 50 Shades of Gray the film
adaptation of el James volcanic novel
that launched the careers of Dakota
Johnson and Jamie Dornan Johnson plays
sexually inexperienced graduate student
Anastasia Steele who starts a romantic
relationship with dornan's Christian
Gray a billionaire who introduces her to
the world of BDSM throughout this film
and the two sequels that would follow
the pair engage in sexual activities
that range from romantic to beyond the
imagination of many some of the more
Infamous moments from the original book
however didn't even make it to the film
one of the more Infamous of these
involves the removal of a tampon
although a memorable moment from the
novel it wasn't even a question that it
would be cut from the film speaking to
Variety in 2015 director Sam Taylor
Johnson admitted it was never even
discussed
a Ryan Murphy Netflix series that aired
for one season this mixed reception show
featured an assemblage of screen and
Stage stars both young and old telling
stories of post-world War II Hollywood
Among the Stars were Samara weaving
Laura Harrier and Jeremy Pope as well as
Murphy regulars Darren Chris Dylan
McDermott and Patti LuPone the latter
portrayed Avis wife of Rob Reiner's Ace
Amberg a studio executive a regular of
McDermott's character's pimp business
she could be seen hiring young men to
satisfy her while Ace was away
surprisingly one cut scene from the
miniseries would have seen LuPone and
Dylan McDermott's characters get
together great
what think about it
the romance between LuPone and McDermott
ultimately never saw the light of day
McDermott claimed their on-screen tryst
was too steamy for viewers eyes while
the Broadway Legend praised her
opportunity to do raunchy sex scenes
elsewhere in the show as she told extra
in reaction to filming love scenes with
McDermott and other male actors finally
what took them so long
few movie characters are as despicably
inappropriate as Jennifer Aniston's
character from The Horrible Bosses films
the fact that she's a woman only makes
it even more off the wall in 2011's
Horrible Bosses she was cast as a
dentist making Relentless unwanted
sexual advances towards her hygienist
Dale played by Charlie Day in response
Dale and his friends played by Jason
Sudeikis and Jason Bateman conspired to
kill each other's bosses and free
themselves of their misery Aniston
reprized the role in Horrible Bosses too
escalating the action significantly and
finally getting her man somewhat in the
film's Final Act Dale wakes up from a
coma after having been shot he learns
that his former boss has become a
helpful almost familial presence while
he was out this is explained in a quiet
moment between the two as Julia reveals
to Dale that she sexually assaulted him
while he was in a coma and is making
plans to seduce his wife next
I'm gonna your wife Dale no no no
it's a crazy reveal and according to
Aniston the filmmakers originally
planned to not just tell it but show it
she stuttered when Conan O'Brien asked
her about the deleted sex scene well it
was kind of not even Mutual you know in
I'm not going to say it but Aniston
explained Charlie Day's character is in
a coma and I exploit him whilst he is in
a coma so it was a sex scene that was
sort of they removed it but I bet it
will be on the DVD extras as it turns
out the scene was not restored for the
DVD and in the years since has not
surfaced publicly in any way most likely
Aniston is breathing a sigh of relief
a runaway hit for Netflix when the first
season premiered in December 2020
Bridgeton based on a series of novels by
Julia Quinn follows the Romantic lives
of the titular Noble family in London in
the early 1800s fans of the show were
particularly swept off their feet by
Phoebe diniver and reggae Jean Page's
performances as Daphne and Simon The
Duchess and Duke of Hastings whose
passionate romantic and sexual chemistry
charged the Show's first season the show
also received notoriety for the use of
intimacy coordinators for its extensive
sex scenes which took pains to view
these activities from the female gays
while the first season inevitably
focused on Daphne and Simon's romance
there are many other romantic plot lines
throughout the season though not
everyone who filmed steamy scenes ended
up having them used in the final show
according to Lizzie Talbot the show's
intimacy coordinator there were more
characters that had intimate scenes that
you didn't see at the end of it all
however the showrunners decided to
prioritize the moments of passion not
necessarily the steamiest some shots
from these omitted scenes can be
glimpsed in the official trailer for the
Netflix series including one where Simon
leaves a sex worker in his bed or
another where he's involved in a
threesome the Marvel Cinematic Universe
has long been conservative when it comes
to love scenes the tradition was broken
somewhat with 2021's eternals when
Richard Madden and Gemma Chan's
characters share the first on-screen sex
scene in An MCU movie but that barrier
would have been broken in a much more
profound way if the Disney plus series
Loki had played out as originally
envisioned in the documentary assembled
the making of Loki on Disney plus head
writer Michael Waldron can be seen
standing in front of a whiteboard filled
with potential series ideas a pause and
a zoom reveals to eagle-eyed viewers
some potential ideas including Tom
hiddleston's god of Mischief traveling
through various time periods collecting
the Infinity Stones end quote doing
crazy Mischief AKA sex another bullet
point reads has the gauntlet holds power
more sex by alien Etc leading some to
believe that the sequence would have
included him having relations with
aliens although Loki ultimately didn't
go down this particular Road the series
did take the opportunity to explore the
character's sexuality in its third
episode where it was revealed that Loki
is bisexual must have been would-be
princesses
or perhaps another Prince
a bit of both
the first two seasons of the crown were
a significant hit on Netflix dramatizing
the young adulthood of Queen Elizabeth
II and her husband Prince Philip Duke of
Edinburgh it brought with it acclaimed
performances from Claire Foy and Matt
Smith who played the queen and her
husband although Foy and Smith were
recast in later Seasons to portray older
versions of the characters they've
remained beloved by fans of the series
for their portrayals however that love
may have been soured if original plans
for season 1 had gone forward according
to Vanessa Kirby who portrayed
Elizabeth's sister Princess Margaret
there was initially going to be a sex
scene between Elizabeth and Philip it
was cut before filming because the
creators deemed that audiences were
likely not interested in seeing the then
still living Queen having sex other love
scenes from The Crown have also never
seen the light of day including a season
2 romp in the hay between Margaret and
Anthony Armstrong Jones played by
Matthew Goode even though that scene was
actually filmed it didn't make it to the
Final Cut of the episode
thank you
[Music]